we're here on overtime here's a question
regarding last week's mortgage
settlements have the banks paid a fair
price for the damage they caused to the
housing market not even close now and
it's getting worse they're gonna be able
to pay their fines with taxpayer money
now what was the settlement it was 420
Friday they paid back 25 cents and we
give them 10 billion dollars in a tax
break I mean the whole thing is it's
it's a bad deal
never should have been caught the only
good news Eric Schneiderman is going to
investigate and continue to investigate
hold their feet to the fire you agree
with that student I think the big
problem with the housing crisis was that
banks and mortgage people took out bad
mortgages and to treat people who are
underwater on their on their mortgages
as victims look the one thing I don't
want to do I don't want to pay for other
people's mortgages I've got a bumper
sticker on my car honk if I paid your
mortgage and everywhere I go people are
honking at me I mean I'm sick you sorry
that twice this is how the Tea Party
movement started people are tired of
having to pay for other people's
mistakes ok we pay for the bank's
mistakes yeah we should have done that
either yeah but we did yeah that's the
problem
but what shape would the country be in
if we hadn't done that what if we hadn't
paid for the bank's mistakes what if we
had no sooner could automobile industry
I mean I saw the head of GM yesterday on
the news say look I'm not trying to get
political he didn't Wayne he said I
don't want to alienate anybody who might
buy a car as a Republican but he said if
Obama didn't do that we'd be dead what
we should have done is cut a deal with
the banks that made sense way back when
we gave them the ten trillion dollars we
should have said now you reform the
mortgages change your practices
restructure the industry be banks not
hedge funds they miss the opportunity
should have put Fannie and Freddie out
of business which maybe sometime maybe
three years here's one you and I might
agree okay President Obama's budget
adequately address entitlement spending
is that a trick question
no no obviously don't you know obviously
there's no entitlement these things are
these are what these are like Batman
they're eating the whole budget they're
eating our whole country yeah well that
there is some a man there
yes 360 billion cut out of yeah out of
like ten trillion is worse going to
spend over the next ten years none of it
is going through so it doesn't matter
maybe the budget doesn't matter at all
and then passed in a couple years well
that's what presidents do they release a
budget it's sort of a blueprint to work
off of at least this budget from this
president was for the first time what he
wanted I thought I thought he's I think
he's learning to negotiate start with
what you really want when you come back
to the middle you'll get half of what
you want as opposed to give it away of
thinking the other guys are nice
how much would voter turnout be affected
if elections were held on Saturdays oh I
think a lot I think a lot more people
would vote if that and this is what most
countries have you know it's a holiday
it should be a holiday shouldn't have to
like leave work and or maybe not be able
to vote at all because you have to work
you know or do electronic electronic or
that there's so many ways and then the
issue of fraud and voting of course you
got to be vigilant we all believe in
that it's really a canard we can do so
many things to get voter participation
to the point where it is in Australia
other countries we showed I'm not sure
about the 1829 demographic though with
Saturday voting I think they like
getting out of work and going on
Tuesdays but people lots of people can't
get out of work well that's true lots of
poor people you know their boss is not
gonna say you sure take off two hours I
mean I think the last two or three
elections we've had would be different
if more people could have gotten off
from work or weren't working that day
you mean McCain might have won I was
taking more the Bush away the other I
always liked was have one person who
votes get a lottery ticket worth a
million dollars so everybody's gonna
turn out and vote and hope they get the
one ticket Wow
I know whose idea was but yeah we don't
show up right that's I never heard that
right yep so bribe them just like hey it
works you know they're doing that with
kids in school now they're you know
they're that's right grades you get you
get bribing kids to go to school I don't
know if that's the best
that we have to pay you to vote and go
to school we are such greedy bastards
okay why is Obama becoming the worst pot
president ever
why doesn't he honor his pledge not to
interfere in state medical marijuana
rights well my theory is because he's
got a lot of other things on his plate
that's another that's another issue you
and I agree on is legalizing pot for
marijuana
I mean marijuana for medical purposes I
mean why shouldn't people it is a very
effective painkiller for people on
chemotherapy and so on and it's it's
cool what why does it have to be just
medical and what about regular you know
look we should decriminalize it because
yes it to spend procedural resources on
pot is ridiculous
what is there a difference between
illegal and D criminal yeah I mean
basically you don't put people in jail
yeah yeah I mean you don't put them in
jail you give him a $5 fine so why not
just like watch eating take we probably
should I mean I think about the way of
fine then I'd be in favor legal legalize
pot legalizing pot is the right word
look I got them over right here on the
air after the show we'll get them over
to do you think that Chris Christie's
veto of the gay marriage bill is not
only dickish but also extremely
short-sighted well it depends on what
short-sighted you're going for I mean
the guys play gonna run in 2016 so for
him running for president running for
president well yeah before I take it
buddy he's doing it for his base but
yeah I mean you know when we went
through the Don't Ask Don't Tell
reversal about a year ago there were
eight Republicans in the Senate who
sided with Democrats on that and five of
them were moderates from blue states and
three of them were younger
conservative Republicans so I think it's
sort of a generational thing it was John
Ensign Richard Burr and Lisa Murkowski
but it's it's more of a generational
thing and yeah and 20 years are probably
it'd be a more normalized thing for most
states okay but but no I mean New Jersey
you know I mean it's my home state so I
take these things a little personally
you know when somebody from New Jersey
does something that I consider sort of
backward and I consider this sort of
backward on the part of the governor it
bothers me it's like because you know
New Jersey the most made fun of states
New Jersey there it's not just from
people from far away it's people in the
area so the one thing we had was always
like well we're from the sophisticated
state of New Jersey from the Northeast
we're not some like you know yokel car
on the lawn state you know we're not
from Alabama or Kansas or somewhere and
then when governor's the governor does
something like this or said that
evolution was none of your business
it just really really bothers me it just
really does it it takes away the one
thing I had but can I say this it is
typical of so much the chris Christie
does he pander
to the very conservative on
pronouncements on all sorts of issues
and you know he's just wrong on
fundamentals could he be the savior of
the party if they go to a convention if
he's a power of the most attractive
candidate he's gifted he's got it he's
tough he's a good speaker and look you
know this you want to have this next
presidential election be about gay
marriage that's one of the reasons that
the the Democrats were lost on the idea
of a savior for the Republican Party I
have met next to no one who has said I
just can't wait for president Rick
Santorum I've met a few Rights who say
that about Mitt Romney I've met a ton of
people who really want chris christie be
to be this christie's your your worst
nightmare why cuz he because he could
work that well then he could be that guy
right okay I don't buy it family
Democrats so what it was yeah I would I
would rather the Democrats run against
Rick Santorum and Chris Christie
absolutely I agree with it we with that
but I don't I don't think chris Christie
withstands the scrutiny because when you
look at so many of the positions he's
taken I just don't think people at the
end of the day either in the compared to
compared to Rick Santorum no no no you
can't use Rick let's bomb Iran and out
you both are missing the point forty
percent of Americans are obese
he's got forty percent of the vote
all right we gotta go thank you
everybody thank you panel Real Time with
Bill Maher ask bill and his guests to
have questions right after the show at
hbo.com